pues sí efectivamente
nunca desde la creación de nuestro
balance anual en
1995 tuvimos un número de periodistas
encarcelados tonales en 2021 tenemos
470 88 periodistas y colaboradores de
medios entre rejas por ejercer su
profesión lo que supone un aumento de
por lo menos 20 por ciento en un año y
esta subida excepcional de las
detenciones tiene que ver también con la
situación especial de tres países
hermanas donde la junta militar de tomar
el poder en febrero de este año pero
también de russian sumida en la
represión tras la reducción del extra
alexander lukachenko y la china de
exigen pin que ha intensificado también
su control sobre la región
administrativa del congo antaño
considerada como el modelo para libertad
de prensa en la zona así que nuestros
tres países tuvimos un aumento
significativo de las detenciones
arbitrales de periodistas y
efectivamente a nivel mundial podemos
decir sí que es cada vez más complicado
más peligroso trabajar como periodista y
esto en casi todos los continentes
infelizmente
bueno y que puede usted de decir de las
declaraciones de beijing que acusan a
estados unidos de tener doble moral al
solidarizarse con el medio hong kong s
pero al mismo tiempo procurar una
extradición del australiano julian
assange se pueden medir los dos casos
con la misma vara
pues si yo no voy a comentar
directamente esta declaración pero sobre
el caso de esther news the day de hong
kong
es importante recordar sí que la mañana
del 29 de diciembre seis miembros del
equipo actual y anterior del sitio de
noticias fueron detenidos y bajo la
acusación de conspiración para evitar
complicaciones deliciosas es un delito
de la época colonial que conlleva una
pena máxima de dos años de cárcel
consideramos gravísimo lo que está
pasando en el brou campus
exactamente seis meses después del
desmantelamiento del grupo next digital
y de su periódico estrella apple daily
podemos decir que la jefa del ejecutivo
de hong kong card y la vuelve a
demostrar su determinación de acabar
totalmente con la libertad de prensa en
el territorio eliminando de forma
similar a after news esto es gravísimo
lo que está pasando y estamos a las
democracias como un todo a actuar de
acuerdo con sus propios valores y
obligaciones y a defender lo que queda
de la prensa libre en un congo antes de
que el modelo chino de control de la
información se cobre otra víctima es es
muy importante denunciar en internet a
nivel internacional lo que está pasando
en el nou con que están intentando
silenciar absolutamente todos los
periodistas independientes y esto es
gravísimo